はい それで次の芸に行きます
質問ありますか？また
はい  無常は目の前に自分も年を取ってシワが増えて髪の毛は薄くなって
母親も死んで焼かれて骨になって友達も亡くなられて骨になって
無常は目の前にあるんですけども
なぜかあの無常ならざるもの
永遠っていうんですか
不滅というか そういうのをなんとなく我々おぼろげながら感ずるので
無常がありながら なぜかそのそれをこう否定がないですけども
それとは違うものは感じながら
無常それほど信仰に行くでもない
それとも我々よほどの川でそれを目の前にありながら感じられないにしては何か理由があるんじゃないですか
それについてお聞きしたいんですけど
答えたいんだけど 無常ならざるものっていうのはどうやって出てくるんですかね
その考え方は  これ考えてる？なんとなくそんな感じですよね
我々は死なないような感じがするわけです
死は目の前にあるわけですけど
体は死ぬんですが 外側は外側の無常は常にあるわけですけど
なんとなく自分が死なないような感じがするわけです
それはおそらくみんななんとなくあるんじゃないでしょうか
みんなあります なんとなくではなくて
なんか死なない感じがするんです
体は死ぬんですけど それは錯覚なのか
希望なのか それとも  希望であって割ついているんですよ
捨てろと それ単なる割愛という仏教パンナーですね
それで問題は なんで無常ならざるものはあると思っているんでしょうかということですよ
それが無常だからなんです
そういう意味です すごいシンプルなところなんですよ
それを発見しないんですよ
人間っていうのは もし無常ならざるものあるならば
そんなありがたかないんですよ
別に ああ そうかということで
なんで人が死ぬことはそんなにショックですかね
魂は永遠だったら なんで我々年取ると何か嫌な気分になるんですかね
どうせ無常ならざるものあるんだったら減っちゃうでしょうに
それは漠然とですけど
明確に 例えば捉えられてないからじゃないでしょうか
明確に我々知っていないのだって
ただ我々の意識の深いところには
その無限といいますか
永遠といいますか 不滅のものがなんか流れてきてるんじゃないでしょうか
だったら安心するでしょう
安心する音が捉えられてないみたい
であるならば なんで人間年取るの？嫌がるんですかね？なんで病気になるの？嫌がるんですかね
苦しいから  苦しくたってどうったことないでしょうに
まず病気で苦しいというのは嫌だと思うんですよ
年を取るっていうのは美しくないですね
普通は  結局美しくいたいでしょう
それは無理ですね 外側の希望として
なぜ死ぬのが怖いんですかね
この無常ならざるもの
永遠たるものに行くでしょうね
死んだら  それは死ぬのが嫌なのは
まだこの人間として生まれたその目的が果たされてないんじゃないのか
じゃあ人間と生まれた目的は何ですかね
今日おっしゃるような悟りじゃないでしょうか
それは嘘でしょう それは私が言った話でしょ
それは わしはなんで人にあなたの目的はこれやと教えてあげなくちゃあかんですか？生きてるのその人でしょうに
私は一人一人人間にあなたの生まれた目的はこれあなた
わしは誰ですかね  それはみんな顔は違うにいろいろ人生は違いますけど
そこは人間共通の  だから人間で生まれたのは私が人間に生まれたんですよ
それは私の勝手であって
そちらは人間に生まれてそちらの勝手であって
お互いに何の関係もないんです
関係ないですけれども
それでそちらが何で生まれたかっていうことをそちらが知るはずなんです
私が何で生まれたかっていうのは私が知るはずなんです
それが何なのかと聞いているんです
そこは意味が果たされないために
果たされていないので
まだ死ねないんじゃないでしょうか
死ぬのが怖い  だから具体的に見れば何なのかとね
だから問題というのは
人間具体的に考えないことなんで
感情で正しいと思っちゃうことなんですね
具体的に 例えば私に聞けば
あんた今死にたいのかと私に聞いてみたら
私は今はちょっと待ってくださいと言うんですよ
具体的に質問したってもいいんです
あんた今死にたいのかと
もし具体的な話は 死ぬ時は死ぬんだから
それはどうしようもないんだけど
でもちょっと待った 待ちなさいでしょうと
私は具体的に頭の中にあるんです
なんで待ちたがっているのかというと
自分で何かやりたい仕事っていうのが決まってるんです
自分が決めたもんなんです
別に生まれつきついたものじゃなくて
自分がやってる仕事が一段落したいという気持ちがあるんです
それから 自分が果たさなくちゃいけない仕事
責任仕事っていうのは
また生まれて大人になってくると自動的についてくるものがあるんでしょうね
例えばそちらにでも子供が生まれたら自動的に責任ついてくるでしょ
子供は一人前にしなくちゃというね
同じ私も人間だから そういう風に大人になってくると自動的についてくる仕事
いくつかあるんですね
それはいくら一段落したいんでしょうね
だから私の場合はもう本当に数えられる
これできて これできて
これできて これできたらまあ終わりと
やることは だから今日死んでくださいといったら
ちょっと待ってよ これやらなくちゃいかんし
これやらなくちゃ これもやるのがあかんでしょうと言うんです
私は正直に それでそちらと私の違うところは
そこがさっきりしてるところなんです
だからってそれ叶えるかとか
それは別な話 だから常にもうほとんど毎日
だから今日明日死んだらどうしようかということで
やっぱり身の回りでもちょこっと整理しなくちゃ
毎日ほどぐらい思うんですよ
と思いつつも整理しないんです
じゃあ明日にやるぞと
だから 自分が生まれてきた目的を果たしてないんだからということはいいんだけど
我々はその それは何やと思ってないんですよ
例えばもうちょこっと仕事をしたいとかね
もうちょっとちょこっと子供たちと一緒にいたいとかね
そんなもんでしょうに
その仕事も我々の生活の糧の仕事と
もう一つ一番重要な仕事
人間としての仕事 我々の今日のような悟り
だからそういうのは正直なところ
もう私の話を聞いてから頭に入った概念ですよ
だから生きることはものすごいバカバカらしいんじゃないか
そんなことばっかりやるのはあなたはと
というふうに私は激しく言ったんだから
ちょこっと考え方が変わったんであって
すべて生命は正直に そんな気持ちでいるわけじゃないんですよ
例えば 子供が大人になって仕事もあってね
結婚したところで じゃあもうあんた死んだらどうでしょうかね
やっぱり孫の顔見たいとかね
で 出てくるんですよ 孫が生まれたらやっぱり幼稚園に行く
幼稚園に連れてきて で
そうやって我々果たしてないということっていうのは
目の前に具体的にあるもんなんですよね
それで奥さんの面倒見ることできなかったとかね
仕事忙しくて いろんなことでね
やっぱりどこかで二人で旅行でもしたいなとかね
そういう具体的なリストがあるんでしょうに
なんでそれ見ないのかと
死にたがらないのはそのためなんです
だから永遠の考え方っていうのは
この渇愛から生まれるんですよ
渇愛っていうのは 何やっても納得いかない
満足できない この世の中で
渇愛っていうのは この無常の論理では確実にあるもので
わざと知恵を発見して捨てるしかないんです
なぜならば すべて無常ということは
すべて不完全ということなんです
すべて それでもしもう最高なおいしい食べ物を食べたならば
もうそれで満足するはずなんです
例えばウナギ食べるとする
これはもうすごい美味しい食べ物と思ってはいる
しかし 自分が食べているあのウナギの一部は
世界で唯一の完璧なおいしいウナギの一部ということではありません
不完全です それで食べる自分の体も不完全なんです
味覚も不完全なんです
それ味も気持ちによって感じたり感じなかったりする
日本にある一流のウナギ食べている時でも
別なことで頭いっぱいになると
例えば会社の関係で もう他の会社から来て
もう自分接待したんだ
それですごい最高なレストラン連れて行って
もう特上のもう特上の特上のウナギをね
もう食べさせてくれたというと
やっぱりまあこれから商談しなくちゃいけないしね
もうというモラルストレスかかるんですよ
こんなご馳走もさせてもらってどうかとかね
だから結局はその気持ちによって味を感じたり感じなかったりする
では 自分のお金で食べればいいでしょ
それでもダメですよ なぜかというと
一食のためにもう 3万円のウナギ食っちゃって
これが申し訳ないと 家族みんなで
これではみんなでどこか出てね
わいわいと食べられるのに
気持ち悪くて出てこないんでしょうね
では すごく超金持ちだったら
また逆に同じことなんです
ただ金あるんだから金ばらまくだけで
すごい頭忙しいんです
だから何やっても全て不完全だから満足ということは成り立たないんですよ
だからもうちょっとやりたいという気持ちが必ず生じるんです
ある日 どこかで安いレストランで私はご飯を食べていたんです
で もう何でもかんでもまずいところでね
ただ  24時間商売やってるところでね
で 自分で料理を選ぶんですね
お店はね というか もう重ねてあって
これこれあと皿に盆に入れて持って行って
それであのレジでお金払って座って食べればいいんです
24時間はやってるんです
で 私はそれで焼き 塩焼きですかね
の魚があって それといくつか選んで
それでお金払って座って食べるとして
一応電子レンジとかあって
それでも温めて温めたって自分でやるんですね
私にとってはこの塩焼きだから
この塩味が辛くてね おいしくないんです
それで塩がついてるところは全部取り取り出すんです
皮のところ全部もう塩見えたらもう全部もう
[笑い]それでご飯と食べてて
それである男性が来て
その人も同じ料理 塩焼きの同じ魚を取っていたんですね
その人ちょっと食べにもさーっと塩かけたの
塩をかけたんです お醤油
大量に 見ただけで まあまあ他を見て
見そうと思いながら 私は一応仏教の者だからね
なるほどなとね と思ったんですよ
それで私ももう塩ついてるところは全部取り出して食べても
私も満足してないし なんであの生魚に大量にベッタベタ塩をつけるのか
焼く前にと私はね あの人にとってはもういろいろ仕事をしてね
もうさっと昼ご飯だからね
もうさっとなんとか食べたいって気持ちでしょうし
だから頭が忙しくてね
で 早く食べていかなくちゃいけない
いろいろあったでしょうにね
だから味は感じないんですよ
あ これもう味だな もうもっとということになるんです
それでは我慢できたんだけど
ご飯にも塩をかけちゃったんです
だから結局は満足しないっていうことになるんでしょうね
だから普通に言えば 100点満点のっていうのはありえません
例えば音楽を聴いて楽しむと 100点満点の曲を 1つ聴いたということはありえないんです
だから生きている私が感じなくちゃいけないでしょ
生きている私がぐるぐるぐるぐる変わっちゃいますからね
気持ちっていうのは 外の世界が変わるだけじゃなくてね
一番ひどいのはこの感じる自分なんですよ
感じる自分がぐるぐる変わってますよ
だからもう何をしても 1 秒の 100分の1でも満足っていうことは感じることはありえないんです
これは論理的にありえないんです
不完全だから 不完全な味覚が不完全なものを食べていると
完全な味わいっていうのはありえないんです
だから割愛っていうのはあるって
それが苦しいんですよ
割愛に気づくことは 人間が幻覚に逃げるんです
苦しみに背くんです ブッダは見なさいよと
事実を見なさいよと 背くんじゃないよと
だからこの苦しみにこの背くために
何か永遠に変わらない何かあるんじゃないかなと
でもあれは幻覚だ だから本気じゃないんだから
不安はそれでも消えません
分かりやすく言えば そのうち宝くじ当たったら大丈夫だというふうに安心するような感じなんです
宝くじ当たったらもう金の問題解決するんだから落ち着けるそれで
しかし 宝くじ当たるってことは不可能ってわけじゃないでしょう
それよりも不可能の幻覚なんですね
あれもう永遠に対する執着は
不可能でない あり得る可能性ある宝くじのことを考えても
我々には経済的には安全することはできません
例えば 確実に１００％の確率で自分に宝くじが当たるという保証があったら
当たる前でも安心するんですよ
まだ当たってない しっかり知ってます
来年2月の宝くじは当たると
一番お金くれるのはいつの宝くじでしたっけ？ 12月ですね
12月では 来年12月の
今年じゃなくて これはもう確実に私に当たると知っている人ならば
今の瞬間からも安心するんです
もう計画立てる もう家をもう買おうと探す
もう設計描いてる 堂々とも発注もする
会社がええ お金なければと言ったらもう借りる
堂々と だからもし永遠の何かあるならば
人間がすごい堂々としているはずなんです
しかし この怯え この不安
瞬間たれても消えませんよ
事実に背負いたっても意味がないんです
自分の家がものすごい火事になって
もうぼうぼうと燃えている時
目を閉じていると見えません
だから大丈夫ですね だからこのいい加減
これはあほらしさと言うんですよ
事実を見ないことにするというね
見ても見なくても事実は事実だからしょうがないんだよと
私はそれを言うのは地球が丸いという例で言うでしょ
いつでも地球が丸いんだから
もうどうしようもないんでしょうに
これは 猫に聞いた猫は
いいえ そんなことはありえないんだと言ったっても丸いんですよ
猫にもミミズにも人間にも
それに背を向けて平らだと思って計算しても
平らだと思って 私は地球の果てに行くぞと
行けるわけないでしょ
自分勝手な妄想で はい
これで世界は終わりと
これは境界線 平らだったら境界線があるんだからね
ですから この無常だからこそ無常しか感じないんだから
無常イコール不完全です
だから変わるんですよ
何か置き物が倒れたということは
これは安定しなかったんだからでしょ
同じく無常だから変わっちゃうんですね
無常ということと変わるということと
次に読めるのは不完全という
それしか経験してないんですよ
その反応で 反動で永遠という概念が生まれるんです
それは単なる逃げだけ
なんで我々はアラディンのランプの話を聞いて楽しかったんですかね
そんなのはないんだからなんです
本当は誰も本気じゃないんです
皆様はいくらか仏教の話を聞いてますけど
確実に永遠の天国があると思っている世界の人々も
ずっと怯えて生活しているんです
あのイスラム人がね なんで世界人類をハチャメチャにしているんですかね
いくらあのヨーロッパ人にね
すごい不公平な扱いをされてもいいんじゃないんですか
それで 自分の権力奪われたって別にいいんじゃないんですかね
だって自分たちが本当の神を信じてるんだから
自分たちしか天国に行けないんだから
アッラーを信じてない人って
みんな永遠の地獄に落ちるんだから
これ土地ぐらい奪ったって
どうぞ奪ってくださいと
持っていってくださいと
言えばいいでしょうに
もしアッラーの教えが
ムハンマドの教えが真理そのものだったら
コーランぐらい便所に流しちゃっても
宗教はどうったことないでしょうに
ムハンマドの人は人間でしたから
漫画描いたってどうったことない
漫画描くしかないでしょうに
もうもう写真はなかったんだから
どうせ地獄に行く連中だから
なんでその人々の財産を壊さなくちゃいけないんですかね
だから本当に信じているのかっていうことですよ
私の問題は 幻覚でインチキで嘘で事実には逆らえないんですよ
結局は とにかくこの短い人生の中で自分の財産を奪われたら
これ困るだけの話でしょうに
みんなそうなんでしょうね
だから本当に我々仏教だから
曲がりなりに輪廻の話やらね
無常の話やら聞いているんですけど
その曲がりなりに聞いてる我々の心の中でも
どこかで永遠という もうなんか安楽の地があるんじゃないかなとかね
もう死んでももう大丈夫じゃないかという
そういう誤解があるし
そんなことなく堂々とあると信じてる人々はどうですかね
より不安でしょうね そこで仏教徒はどうでしょうかと
全て無常やと 永遠なんかくそくらえ
あるわけないよというのに
全然驚きませんよ 何があっても
すごく冷静にいる 自分の国でも毎日のように殺されてますよ
仏教の人々 誰も攻撃はしません
その上新聞も BBC やらももう出来事起こる前に記事書いてるんです
自分たちが計画を立てて
もう教会といろいろキリスト教関係でね
もう爆弾が起こったり
もう船を爆破させたり
人を殺したりして そこを出来事起こる前に記事書いて
仏教徒はこういう風なもうもうもうもう血に飢えていて
こんなことする こんなことすると書いてるんです
だからこのrepressionと英語で言うんですけど
この なんて言いますか
この 死海 死海じゃ何でしたっけ
仕返しする 仕返でしたっけ Reprisals
は なんかやったらやり返すこと
仕返し だから仕返ししたんだという記事ですよ
でも仕返ししてないんです
記事だけもう流すんです
世界的に この間 BBC
のあるリポーターの記事を読んでみたんですけど
BBC といえば世界的に一番あの
あのバランス取ってニュース流せるだと自慢しているでしょう
アメリカの ABC やら CNN と違って
ああいうのは明らかにもうある会社のある一部の情報しか流せませんだけど
BBC はすごいもう均等にという自慢話ばっかりして
何があるかというと この人か何人かのただこの平和条約破ってテロたちがもう殺しちゃったんですね
で それに合わせて記事が出ています
このシンハレ人のこの態度は何なのかとかね
言って このちょうどその時自分が行くんですね
行ったらこのどこかどこかでこのもうデモがあったと
我々にも怒鳴りつけたんだと
一人が手を握って もう車の中にこうやって手を見せたんだと
こいつら血に飢えているんだと
あの自分たちがやったことに対して全然一言も触れないんです
人殺さないよとデモぐらい行ったって言ってやったって
もう何が悪いんですかね
単なるデモでしょうに
家に石を投げませんでしょうに
ガラスは割らないでしょうに
人にデモする自由があるでしょうに
民主主義な国だから それでその視界ももう記者にね
悪口言ったことまで正しいでしょうに
お前らはもう嘘ばっかり世の中で流してるんではないかと
それはその通りでしょうに
それで最後の結論 あの国には平和は訪れません
あれはもう血の Sri Lanka has a history of only blood. という
それ聞いて人殺して人殺しの歴史は誰が持ってるんでしょうかと
だからそこまで嘘を言うんでしょうに
誰とも戦争したことは
戦争したことはないし
まあ微妙に昔から 2500年の歴史の中でね
地方の争いとかね インドから占領されちゃって
それからもうやがて嫌になっちゃって追い出されたという
もうちょこちょこっとのことはあるんだけど
それっていうのはもう当たり前の話でしょうに
人間の歴史では そこまで不公平ですけど
仏教徒は落ち着いていますよ
全然 ただ落ち着いているだけで
きちっと自分たちの命を守っているんです
何の武器も持たず 国の法律でも法律で
もうテロリストはもうフレイムや爆弾やらあれこれと
もう世界一の恐ろしいもの全部持ってますけど
我々はちょこっと長い包丁を持っていても逮捕されるんです
シンハラ民族すごい厳しいんです
向こうの悪い人間やらね
もう暴力やってる連中やらいろいろ持ってますけどね
泥棒やってる連中やらね
それでももし捕まったらもうもう徹底的にもう裁かれます
だからまあ言いたがっているのは
この無常ってもう何でもそんなもんかと
行為に結果あるんだぞと知ってる人っていうのはね
それは事実ですからね
それは本気です だからそれなりに生き方をしているんです
神を信仰している人こそ本気ですかと